what to play i'll play a bird
just wanted to say you're one of my
favorite chess players
pogba's poggers thanks for that
i'm playing a bird inspired by by kimmy
lou would you consider making a game
with you a possible channel point
redemption for people
who can't afford a subscription very
possibly
the issue with that is if a bunch of
people redeem a game at once
it's just a matter of tracking it with
like a cue
i'm gonna have to look into like the
channel point redemption thingies
um because i've already have the problem
with opening
opening requests like i just got flooded
and it's hard to fulfill all the
requests
i could make it really expensive that's
true
supply and demand okay this is
basically a polar bear
now you know
i like how it spells out traxler welcome
back add fast
yeah addfost was a star in my most
recent two youtube videos
has a q system built in for things like
that
i'll look into it between streams
and maybe by the next stream i'll i'll
have it figured out
because i know there's some setting to
like limit the number of redemptions
anyway okay going for this uh kind of
typical setup
maybe we'll get one stafford gambit the
stream
or one jerome i don't know
it's hard to satisfy everyone
oh thanks so much akd 707 gifting a sub
to ie plato
i'll probably interweave some just
random viewer challenges too
so even if you're not a sub or you
haven't connected your name
uh there'll still be opportunities
play this move this is reminding me like
a a reverse nimzo indian
i want to play knight chief knight g4 is
kind of a cool move
at some point
oh it's toggy going back to work bye
tagi hope you're doing well
enjoy the work enjoy the icelandic
weather
maybe soon to be winter
[Music]
yeah this is kind of a cool attacking
move
oh
eric rose and stafford gambit is not
enough when i played
oh it and then i stomped them
oh that's so great
that's so great good job emblem i'm so
proud
and bro swole
thanks for subbing with prime bro
swole it's a very masculine name
i'll admit okay so the reason why i was
trying
so i was waiting for g6 i was gonna try
and pretend to mouse up knight g4
say oh no my queen and then checkmate as
a bishop
but none of that happened
i was hoping for another oh no my queen
moment
i'm still playing viewers yes
um except i don't know if my opponents
are actually viewing the stream
it's likely i don't mind one way or the
other i can set
channel point redemptions to be
requested a certain amount of times in
one day
yeah i do that with a blindfold
redemption i think the max is like three
let's defend again we could end up
repeating a little bit
ah okay i'm not repeating
times the rose and gamba to queen sack
with mate in two
i don't think it's happening though i
wanted it to happen
how do i how do i be tricky play this
move
anyway
okay i have a lot of pieces like aimed
at the king side
in various ways
right can you draw arrows to like make
the whole board green
maybe yeah
how green can i make the board
it's probably not the best use of my
time
like there's so many more productive
things i can do in life
but this is weirdly satisfying
this is really i don't know why i didn't
discover this earlier
i feel like picasso accepts
a slightly worse version
wow now the queen saw oh and the arrows
stay
oh no my queen ah i wanted to move back
to h5
hmm i wanted to repeat again to gain
more time because the opponent's
hesitating
ah
that's okay i'll win the pawn for it
yeah i take that hakaru karl can't mess
with those arrows
opponent's gonna flag being so perplexed
or doesn't move and not getting mated
unfortunately
[Music]
wait i think i'm just winning here
am i this is check
oh this is working out beautifully
how do i meet
i have to be precise
i i if i could do this it's just i think
winning on the spot
but
um i play this move
i think actually this might work
let's do it i wanted to play this move
but then black and take and then move
here and help defend
so the whole point i'm just freeing the
square for the rook
oh no my knight should have said that
sooner
but chat knows how to say it good job
chat
a black spawn structure
what is this shape
kind of like a y
yeah queen h6 was actually kind of a
cool move
uh thanks for the game fano
uh because i'm threatening mate i think
f6 is probably a better
response um
this was intentional of course if if
takes it's the same uh
knight plus bishop mating idea
so this reminded me this line we went
into is almost like an exactly reverse
version
uh one of the very first lines i ever
learned
in the nimzo indian defense
this is back to more serious
instructional chess
so nimzo indian white goes for this
eric what your thoughts on the recent
online chess cheating incident t
gran wait let me show this first
so this is one of the main lines of the
the nimzo
uh we can see okay a lot of master level
games
a lot of lee chess games uh so it's very
natural for white
to uh like try and fight for this square
so white will usually go for a
combination of this
and this uh so let's say queen c2
yeah most common move black plays f5 to
reinforce the square
now knight d2 most common move
and now here there's a cool line queen
h4
and if y plays g3 which looks really
natural
actually g3 looks really good to try and
deflect the queen
away from defending the knight because
there's three attackers
this is where uh actually i'll give this
to chat
black to move find the best move let's
see if chad has been playing
or paying attention
one suggestion for g5
it's a right square
but oh some people saying knight g3
knight g3 would be great if white had to
take back this way because we mate
unfortunately knight g3 f takes g3 and
we lose a knight for a pawn
but good job chat knight to knight g5
the same idea i use pretty much same
pattern
here it's you basically have to do it to
not lose material
let's see before i turn on opening book
let's guess how many people fell in fell
for mates
after pawn takes queen
i'm guessing a couple dozen maybe like
let's say 20.
it could be over 100 but this is more
specific
line and if white's going to go into
this white's probably a decent player
i'm thinking 20 but let's see
13. 13 people got mated like this
oh but there's other ways to get mated
too
uh yeah like f4 gets mated
f4 knight h3 mate um
oh maybe i was close with my 20 yes
because if we add up g takes h4 that's
13
uh this stops me at the stops mate 13
plus 5 is
18. rookie one stocks mate oh so there
are 19 people that end up getting mated
so i was close
yeah it's a nice opening trap it's a
cool line too because it flows
really nicely like first you play
positionally then you
you get sometimes get rewarded with
tactics